ГПУ ще ніколи не була настільки успішною, як тепер.
Про це заявив її очільник Юрій Луценко
через два з половиною роки після призначення.
Дозволю собі побути нахабним:
за результатами я - найуспішніший генеральний прокурор України.
Щонайменше з 2000-х.
З великою повагою ставлюся до попередніх,
але з початку 2000-х результати роботи ГПУ зараз найкращі.
Юрій Луценко - 14-й генеральний прокурор України за всю історію держави,
і восьмий - від початку 2000-х.
Якщо згадати Михайла Потебенька, за каденції якого загинув В'ячеслав Чорновіл,
Олександра Медведька, на часи якого припали отруєння Ющенка,
загибель Кушнарьова та дивні самогубства Кірпи і Кравченка,
або Віктора Пшонку - генпрокурора Віктор Януковича,
то, звичайно, порівняння - на користь Луценка.
Але за оцінками експертів Центру політико-правових реформ
та Amnesty International Ukraine,
порівнювати слід не з попередниками, а з можливостями голів ГПУ.
І якщо попередні генпрокурори були повністю залежними від своїх президентів,
то Юрій Луценко отримав значно більше можливостей
і прийшов на посаду після Революції Гідності як людина,
що не пов'язана з системою:
почалися антикорупційні реформи, а сам він міг розраховувати
на підтримку і громадянського суспільства, і західних партнерів.
Проте досягення Луценка - неспівмірні з його обіцянками
оновити систему та побороти корупцію.
За часів чинного глави ГПУ Інтерпол зняв з розшуку
Віктора Януковича та Андрія Клюєва,
а суд Євросоюзу в Люксембурзі
регулярно скасовує санкції з оточення Януковича,
бо українська прокуратора досі не завершила
жодної справи проти них.
Досі немає процесів за вбивства на Євромайдані.
Напади на активістів перебувають на особливому контролі,
але результатів немає,
прориву щодо вбивства Павла Шеремета
за два з половиною роки - так само.
В афері з "вишками Бойка", що стала символом масштабної корупції
попередньої влади, ГПУ не знайшла слідів самого Юрія Бойка,
є проблеми і з провадженнями проти Юрія Іванющенка
через некомпетентність прокуратури,
а, наприклад, з шести справ проти екс-міністра Миколи Злочевського
чотири вже закриті, а у двох винними в розкраданнях проходять інші особи.
Звинувачення проти так званих діамантових прокурорів
досі ні до чого не призвели.
Як, власне, і помпезне затримання Військовою прокуратурою
екс-податківців Клименка з 15 областей України.
Нині усі затримані вийшли з-під варти.
Розслідування справи про держзраду Віктора Януковича
завершилось судовим вироком,
проте до вердиктів у корупційних справах Януковича ще далеко.
До своїх здобутків ГПУ зараховує повернення
півтора мільярда доларів екс-президента,
проте ймовірність того, що його адвокатам вдасться
скасувати це рішення через європейські суди - досить велика.
Системного оновлення кадрів в ГПУ також досі не відбулося.
Позитив у тому, що Юрій Луценко дозволив створити
органи прокурорського самоврядування, які наглядають за його діяльністю,
але відкритого конкурсу на всі посади в ГПУ немає,
призначення відбуваються в ручному режимі,
а прокурори досі фінансово залежні від керівництва.
Крім того Юрій Луценко - політик, який часто-густо
керується політичною, а не правовою доцільністю.
На усі закиди Юрій Луценко традиційно заперечує:
справи розвалюються, бо суди нереформовані,
а боротьба з масштабною корупцією -
насправді відповідальність НАБУ та САП.
Проте перешкоджання роботі Національного антикорупційного агентства -
одне з найбільш серйозних обвинувачень на адресу Луценка з боку країн Заходу,
а Спеціалізована антикорупційна прокуратура - структура ГПУ,
її очільник Назар Холодницький - заступник Луценка.
Відсутність судової реформи дійсно проблема,
проте не меншою бідою є і брак хороших кадрів в ГПУ
та слабка підготовка доказової бази,
через що професійні адвокати часто легко розвалюють справи в судах.
На сайті ГПУ на першій сторінці - звіт про результати роботи.
За попередні два роки - понад 6 тисяч переданих до суду справ
та майже дві з половиною тисячі вироків.
Та поточною роботою займалися й попередні генпрокурори.
Ці ж цифри - не зовсім те, що Луценко - давній борець з корупцією -
обіцяв та мав усі повноваження досягти.
На переконання опитаних експертів, системних та незворотніх змін
так і не відбулося. А в разі політичної реакції
наступний генеральний прокурор зможе
за півдня скасувати всі успіхи Юрія Луценка.